[Musique]
chantal hébert stéphanie grand monde
chez elle devait de bonsoir bonsoir mon
copain on a l'impression qu'on est de 22
grande impuissance collective
et un peu de flou face à cette violence
quoi faire devant cette violence en
montée il faut quand même l'admettre le
dire à montréal les deux mortes sas a
cristallisé un sentiment qui étaient
déjà là avant cet été chantal hébert
vous avez vu on va les entendants
quelques minutes mais madame anglade est
entré dans la partie et monsieur duhaime
a fait à peu près tout le monde
comment vous décoder ce qui est en train
de se jouer qu'est ce que c'est un enjeu
qui ne veut pas pour faire parti de la
lampe
jusqu'à un certain point et 20 petit
côté vautours qui se lancent sur le
morceau de viande dans ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui ça fait partie de ce
qu'on pourrait appeler la game période
électorale néanmoins il y en a pas de
solution magique
demain matin quelqu'un va pas arriver et
dire voilà j'ai trouvé une solution est
d'ailleurs quand on écoute le contenu de
ce que tout le monde dit ça se ressemble
beaucoup il n'ya pas aller au pot 56
façon de gérer ça ça va prendre le temps
que ça prend ça prend aussi trois
gouvernements et probablement que la
bonne nouvelle là dedans c'est que il y
au moyen d'un gouvernement qui est
certain de s'y impliquer pour des
raisons qui la menthe âge c'est à dire
le parti libéral fédéral d'une part
parce qu'ils ont des projets de loi sur
le contrôle des armes à feu qui veulent
faire avancer cet automne mais d'autre
part parce que une partie critique la
députation au fédéral est tenu à ses
fans et michel
rester là évidemment rester la gare 10
quand est ce que vous vouliez dire on va
attendre madame anglade et monsieur
james n'était pas avec nous plutôt
convient tout de suite
est-ce que vous avez vu le premier
ministre ici à montréal récemment vient
nous parler des enjeux de sécurité
publique n'accepte pas je n'accepte pas
de voir qu on gère ce qui se passe
présentement
à coup de tweets puis deux zones
c'est bien beau de faire des tweets par
ceux attachés politiques ou de faire des
déclarations sur internet mais je pense
que la première chose à faire c'est de
venir avec la population de sentir les
gens de parler aux gens de rencontrer
les intervenants locaux
stéphanie vous attendez à quoi
maintenant des la mairesse de québec
d'ottawa
oui mais c'est ça et effectivement on
peut on peut bien décrié comme madame en
la magie du hem le faisait il ya de la
récupération politique là dedans mais
après qu'est ce qu'on fait donc c'est
sûr que la mairesse de montréal a
vraiment le problème dans les jambes le
directement on sait que évidemment l e
comme un peu il ya une perte de
confiance la forme des policiers parce
que c'était son parti s'était un peu
prononcé halle en faveur du des
financements de la folie c'est le ainsi
un de ses candidats qui étaient
ouvertement leur faveur de deux des
financements est là donc il essaie de
laisser d'avoir un leadership mais en
tant que les troupes lécher les
policiers le ya quand même un manque de
confiance on sait comme si l'embargo est
aussi on attend des mesures le de sa
femme parce que ces derniers mois elle
les problèmes les fusillades se
multiplient puis on n'a pas vraiment vu
lors il semble que les indications sont
payés fait qu'il va y avoir des mesures
plus de
visibilité peut-être une escouade qui se
mettra en branle tant mieux parce que
évidemment il faut il faut plus de il
faut plus de visibilité il ya comme un
sentiment d'impunité en ce moment c'est
ça que je pense les gens constate c'est
que on est rendu qu'on peut tirer en
pleine rue et en plein jour dans les
quartiers où il ya où il ya plein de
monde et puis ça dérange plus donc c'est
ça qui est un peu
impressionnant de la dernière à
conquérir crime qu'on a vus mais québec
a aussi ses devoirs à faire le fédéral
c'est vrai chant paul ii disait ont agi
avec le projet ses 21 là pour
réglementer davantage les armatures mais
c'est beau d'interdire de mettre un
jeune sur les armes légales sauf qu'en
même temps et beaucoup d'âme qui passe
par la frontière ce sont des armes
inégales et tout le monde sait que c'est
c'est des enjeux comment on va faire
pour mieux contrôler ça et il ya une
partie du problème qui passe par les
réserves autochtones et aussi il ya des
gens qui peuvent commander des pièces
tout simplement parce que ça sape a été
visé par le projet de loi et se sublimer
et un cadre de deux dames furent
fabriqués par part donc encore
david donc êtes vous d'accord qu'il n'y
a pas de solution magique mais les gens
s'attendent néanmoins un plein exposit a
des annonces cela bien évidemment que
les gens s'attendent à ça et à la veille
d'une campagne électorale un incident
comme celui là peut pas ne pas être
récupéré on a vu madame anglade c'est
pas pour y est je pense surtout à madame
anglade parce que monsieur duhaime a pas
beaucoup d'espoir à montréal mais madame
anglade il ya plusieurs de ces
circonscriptions qui sont menacés par la
cac alors pour elle y est bien important
de démontrer ou d'essayer dé montrer aux
gens que françois legault il ce sac de
montréal que ces gouvernements des
barbus que tout ce qui se passe à
montréal ça n'intéresse pas que j étais
pas là il y envoyer des tweets alors
qu'au moment où il y avait eu le drame
de l'halloween à québec la liste est
précipitée pour pour déplorer tout cela
ça c'est dans l'ordre des choses
maintenant monsieur legault j'écoutais
surtout parce que sur le goût et une
réaction un peu c'est vrai un peu rapide
mais madame guigou la mineuse à sécurité
publique a dit écoutez là on est
d'accord qu'il faut faire quelque chose
mais les premiers sur le terrain c'est
la ville de montréal envoyez-nous déçus
des propositions et demande si ça prend
de l'argent il va y en avoir et mais ça
règle pas tous les problèmes mais je
pense que il faut qu'ils aient d'une
manière ou d'une autre plus de policiers
qui chasse qui font font font la chasse
aux criminels et ça ça va pas en
opposition avec la prévention des
problèmes sauf semble-t-il pas un
spécialiste la police mais un des
problèmes c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
policiers actuellement qui font du
travail communautaire qui sont pas
précisément à la chasse aux criminels et
ce travail là pour être fait davantage
et peut-être même mieux par d organismes
communautaires qui sont sur le terrain à
plein temps alors là je pense qu'il ya
une voie là dedans maintenant pour ce
qui est du fédéral écoutez le projet de
loi c 21 correspond mauvais en soi mais
je pense la police de toronto qui disait
l'an dernier coûté 86 % déjà les armes
saisies c'est des armes illégales y sont
ils sont sas acheté au noir alors c'est
pas un projet qui interdit la vente qui
vont empêcher les gens d'en acheter au
droit est temps que les américains oea
vont considérer les armes à feu comme
des jouets ils savent où est assez
facile pour quelqu'un de s'en procurer
le bas très bien on va évidemment
revenir dans cette campagne rachat du
pôle québec parrot avoir bloqué par le
gouvernement du québec
chantal juin je vous ai vu réagir comme
cela on me dit du québec fait exprès
pour bloquer sa pour mousser son
plaidoyer pour un troisième lien
non c'est sûrement il ya d'autres
détails plus complexes mexique qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce que vous lisez vous là
dedans
bon moi je n'en connais pas autant dans
ce dossier leur lancée j'ai néanmoins
noté que qu'il a prédit tendance est
d'accord d'ici la fin de la campagne
électorale ça dossier lgv va se régler
d'une façon du nom parce qu'ils aient
changé un pont aujourd'hui pour un
troisième lien demain même si on aime le
troisième mais c'est bien mauvais
échanges c'est comme si je vous disais
vous pouvez mettre votre tour dans le
garage ont beaucoup donné trottoir dans
cinq ans pour la sortir de l'eau vous
allez répondre b non réparer mon
trottoir en attendant donc si c'est ça
le calcul ça me semble un mauvais calcul
et un d'autant plus mauvais calcul que
quand des gens comme le maire actuel de
québec où le maire précédent au québec
dit ceci n'est que de la partisanerie
c'est pas une bonne place où on veut
être dans une campagne électorale qui
commence ouais ben c'est exactement à
monsieur david j'ai peut-être avais-je
entendu le maire de québec qu'on veut
entendre d'après qui la règle soit au
plus vite la et le maire de lévis aussi
en passe de régler sont privés
maintenant vous savez le pont il tombera
pas dans le prochain mois l'artiste y a
pas d'entente avant l'élection c'est pas
la fin du monde pourra toujours le faire
après ça on a l'impression d'un vieux
film je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
patrice il ya trois ou quatre ans
c'était la chicane à mort entre la town
québec pour la peinture ou la la stèle
il l'a même la même affaire sauf que
meta les chiffres sont multipliées par
50 je sais pas mais on dirait qu'il ya
c'est dans l'adn des deux longs de
chicaner et à ce moment ci monsieur
legault a besoin d'un adversaire qui
peut étrillé un peu parce que les autres
partis qui sont dans la course seul tout
le monde sait que la partie est jouée
alors çà il prend un méchant dans son
dans son script et ottawa fait fait ce
rôle là à merveille alors qu'on règle la
question après parce qu'elle va se
régler je ne sais bien mais je vois pas
pourquoi on se dépêcheraient de le faire
alors qu'on peut on peut s'en servir
pendant quelques semaines quelqu'un qui
est plus pressé que vous c'est le maire
marchand l'écoutent
x 10.6 débrouillez vous livrer les
résultats moi je pars à table je vois
savoir qui bloque qui bloque peau mais
quelque chose qui marche pour les russes
qui fonctionne pas c'est pas pour ça que
les gens nous helix les gens nous
élisent pour qu'on fasse des discours
pour qu'on fasse du blocage pour qu'on
fasse ex y ait les mains pour lequel on
n'a pas de réussite on a besoin de
résultats on a besoin de refaire de ce
pont leur joyau si ce concept
ils vont charrette il dit ce matin que
on bloque
donc en train de négocier une entente ou
le gouvernement du québec dans la main
que tu négocies pour le fédéral vont
assumer 50 bon sens des coûts de
réfection au dessus de 350 millions
depuis qu'un gouvernement du québec dans
une entente fédérale cn devrait assumer
la moitié des coûts d'entretien alors ce
qu'on entend c'est que une des raisons
pour lesquelles ça se ferait ce serait
de donner un argument de plus pour un
autre projet le projet de troisième bien
il faut que tout le monde revienne à la
raison et continuent et continuent à
travailler de bonne foi sur cette
question importante
ouais c'est parti la corde etc au
parti ces familles un petit mot pour
conclure là dessus le troisième ça
dépasse largement la région de québec ça
sera un enjeu national
c'est évident et clair mais je pense
que c'est un projet qui a été lancé pour
qui a été la cible dans une campagne
électorale pour essayer de séduire des
électeurs mais on a fait sauter
complètement à lanvin au lieu de partir
du besoin qui à mon sens existe
peut-être peau et ensuite essayer de
trouver le meilleur projet pour
améliorer la la le trafic à québec et
ben on a fait tout à l'envers on
s'avance avec un avec un troisième ligne
et on s'est toujours pas l'impression
que ça répond au besoin on a pas d'étude
pour pour s'appuyer ça c'est un creux
difficile de débattre de tout ça
j'entends jonathan notre collaborateur à
québec je l'entends pomme je l'entends
dans la tête que tout aimé vous êtes 3 4
qui
vivez à montréal mais ça va être
le maire de québec lui vit à québec
et le maire labeaume ongles ancien maire
labonté aussi excusez nous mais c'est
bien eux qui disent s'excuser la bonne
moi je suis que le porte parole n'a
évidement il savait ça va être un débat
passionné d'ailleurs notre ancien
collègue martin qui assure ce panel
avait des soulignait comme vous
l'absence de chiffres et c'est là dit
non non non tout le monde est d'accord
le maire une demi-heure après lui a
répondu non je faisais des nouvelles
pour vous on n'est pas tous d'accord à
québec il reste 5 minutes françois
philippe champagne moi ce matin à l'aube
j'ai vu ça
un peu plus tard que chantelle guise la
barre au plus tôt et je me suis dit
bon c'est yann campagne au leadership
qui se prêtera pas ce qu'on peut bien
venez collègues dans les bureaux de
ministres pas loin qu'on dise pas normal
que notre collègue françois philippe
champagne ne parle pas plus français que
ça ça c'est une première réaction que
j'ai eu ensuite en voyant ce décor de
notre ami le blanc effectivement
françois philippe champagne sur tous ces
discours l'anneau à peu près pas parler
français
comment vous voyez ce chantal comment
vous avez réagi à ces
baies d'abord je pense que le ministre
se rend pas compte on fait attention à
ce qu'il fait et maintenant il sait que
c'est pas juste de couper un ruban ou de
faire des annonces qui
vont lui donner des résultats ensuite
j'ai trouvé ce gênant pour lui très
franchement surtout quand on compare ça
et c'est pas gentil mais c'est réel à
christophe willem qui est même pas
député du québec et qui se promènent
d'un bout à l'autre du canada qui fait
15% de ses interventions à l'extérieur
du québec en français lui a l'air de
dire qu'ils s'en est pas rendu compte
que le fait peut-être francophone pour
tenir de shawinigan c'est bleu dire que
c'était pas un problème mais oui c'est
un problème le l'idée que le français
s'est réservé au québec et encore puis
que partout ailleurs mais il n'y a pas
de problème bonjour et merci ça suffit
c'est pas nécessairement quelque chose
qui va dans le sens de l'idée que le
gouvernement fédéral représente
une conception du bilinguisme qui fait
une place au français à l'extérieur de
la limite de l'outaouais qui lui il fait
pop avec les chiffres connus tse canada
en plus il ya quelques jours c'est fanny
réaction bah justement là je fais miens
moi aussi avec les chiffres qui sont
sortis de statistique canada la semaine
dernière ça montre peut-être ce prix de
france est là dans les discours de
monsieur champagne la latitude général
des gens à ottawa pour le français parce
qu'on voit dans les chiffres de
statistique canada que le bilinguisme
est pas en recul partout au canada sauf
au québec où il est en augmentation mais
ça c'est intéressant de le souligner
c'est comme si au québec on ressemble de
plus en plus et peut-être certains pays
européens où il ya du bilinguisme déjà
par deux trois langues et ça c'est tant
mieux mais dans le reste du canada on
ressemble de plus en plus aux états unis
où c'est une seule langue l'anglais qui
domine et dans les décisions à ottawa
ailleurs nié qui est là pour freiner la
tendance malheureusement l'immigration
francophone par exemple ils avaient des
cibles ne sont jamais atteinte donc il
ya vraiment du travail à faire de ce
côté là on peut évidemment mais la
nomination de noeud du gouverneur
général qui ne parle pas français mais
c'était un peu la cerise sur le gâteau
je devais de gâche vraiment comment vous
avez interprété ce matin ces gars une
gaffe évidemment sur le plan politique
mais et je trouve que c'est pire que ça
chantal 10e adam freeland parle beaucoup
mieux et un peu mieux mais beaucoup plus
français on présente la même chose à
l'époque de stephen harper c'est comme
si les ministres francophones quand il
envoie à l'extérieur avec sentait le
besoin de s'excuser de l'être il parle
moins français et je pense qu'il est
très malheureux parce que et là il
comprend vraiment pas le genre de pays
que les libéraux prétendent vouloir
incarner
c'est tout le monde sait bien que quand
monsieur champagne doit ça va aussi va
faire une annonce en ontario en
colombie-britannique les gens à qui
s'adresse comprennent pas le français
c'est pas pour l'heure de donner de
l'information qui doit parler français
c'est simplement pourrait affirmer en
tant que détenteur de l'autorité
publique que les deux langues s'expose
est une réalité pas simplement une
phrase décrit dans un projet de loi dans
une constitution est ici le fais pas ça
c'est bien malheureux mais il comprend
vraiment pas le pays que prétend
défendre son chef et son parti et sam
autres aussi chantal que derrière le
ministre son appareil ses rédacteurs ses
conseillers le tas non mais que que lui
c'est comme si ils oublient le français
parce que beaucoup de gens autour de lui
ne le parle absolument pas bon d'abord
cinq minutes stupide et ensuite si oui
les actions staff lui donne plus de
français dans ses disques au son staff
lui donnerait plus de français dans ses
discours mme adam freeland en obtient
donc
ça le préoccupe manifestement pas et
c'est un bon rappel à tous ses collègues
et à lui-même que
oui encore des gens qui survivent être
et qui a intérêt à se réveiller là
dessus parce que c'est probablement la
chose qu'il donne le sens de magie
depuis qu'il est devenu ministre au sein
du script d'un fédérer très bien merci à
vous trois à très bientôt au revoir
bonne soirée au revoir on m'envoie